the town of region is dying
i said if someone doesn't do something
this community will be a dead community
i have a paved road from interstate to
region now what do i do to bring people
down 30 miles
then it dawned on me nobody is going to
drive 30 miles for normal sculptures but
they might drive for the world's largest
i started the enchanted highway in 1989
i've been at it for 28 years
and it takes me roughly about four to
five years to do one sculpture
the first year
local ranchers taught me how to weld
i put in eight hours a day to get one
sculpture done
i use old oil well tanks i cut them open
and i flatten it out and that's 90
percent of my metal
it's a passion project right now
it started with the world's largest tin
family the man is 45 feet tall the woman
is 43 feet and the boy is 23 feet
geese in flight has over 300 length of
oil well pipe on over 15 miles of weld
on it and is in the guinness book of
records the world's largest scrap metal
sculpture
that's something i will continue on
until i'm six feet under and then i hope
it continues on after that
i want people to see that this guy who
didn't know how to weld didn't have an
art class if he can create something
like this i can do most anything
you